[Musique]
depuis la semaine dernière l'hôpital
d'armentières compte deux soignants de
moi une infirmière et un puériculteurs
contrôlé par la drh n'ont pas pu
présenter de passer ni terre tous deux
ont refusé d'être testé ils ont été mis
en congé des cas pour l'instant isolées
ou les soignants savent que dès le 15
septembre ils devront avoir reçu au
moins une injection au 16 octobre ils
devront être entièrement vacciner faute
de quoi ils seront suspendus le premier
ministre jean castex l'a confirmé ce
matin ne reculerons pas dire quoi nous
n'aurons qu'à partir du 15 les les
sanctions prévues par le gisti leur
seront mises en oeuvre des médecins qui
s'inquiètent de la rentrée et cette
question est ce que les non vaccinés
vont nous pourrir la rentrée 32 16
rmc.fr les situations sanitaires
s'améliore en métropole aujourd'hui 2000
personnes sont hospitalisées dont 2000
en réanimation des chiffres en baisse la
quatrième vague n'est pas encore
derrière nous mais elle tend à diminuer
elle pourrait diminuer encore davantage
mais nous entrons néanmoins dans une
zone d'incertitude lié à la fin de l'été
maintenant que l'économie française
rodez ma que nous avons des perspectives
de croissance à 6 % je le dis le quoi
qu'il en coûte c'est fini nous sommes
passés au sur mesure nous restons
favorables à un monde ouvert et libre
échangiste
vrai paquet d'ambiguïté nous sommes
faveur du libre-échange s'est livrée
chance dont je peux parler
pas invité dominique strauss kahn donc
priori
et puis ce couac au plus haut sommet de
l'état emmanuel macron avait annoncé sur
twitter s'être fait vacciner le 31 mai
mediapart a consulté les données de
l'assurance maladie selon lesquelles il
aurait été vaccinées le 13 juillet soit
au lendemain de son allocution sur le
passage était organisée a évoqué une
erreur de saisie dans la transmission
des données à l'assurance maladie
politiquement il n'est rien il saupoudre
une pincée de chaque couleur politique
selon les jours dans un savant dosage il
ne croit en rien n'a aucune conviction
d'abord moi j'ai cru qu'il parlait de
lui-même françois hollande quand il
parlait de ça ce qu'on en fait mais oui
donner ses effets en fait il s'est fait
avoir il a failli on lui a fait ce qu'il
fait aux autres depuis des années
peut-être dire qu'il a passé ses enfants
mais bien sûr donc après ce quelque
chose il est tombé sur quelqu'un de plus
intelligent que lui
président dela
en plus que lui donne des leçons
d'élégance qui n'a même pas été capable
de raccompagner nicolas sarkozy sur les
champs elysées le jour de la passation
de pouvoir du musée fleury absolument
choquant bon voilà et puis son
quinquennat deux à la fois rappelé
durable la manière dont il s'est
comporté avec valérie trierweiler cela
n'est pas quand même terrible ils ont le
don qu'il n'a pas brillé par l'élégance
il est beau toujours à l écoute et
répond au message dans ma seconde
mais il ça a trouvé le petit ami idéal à
un détail près c'est être exceptionnel
n'existe pas il est totalement virtuel
j'ai vraiment l'impression d'être dans
une relation je sais que ce n'est pas un
être humain mais au moins je ne suis
plus comme j'étais à attendre bêtement
une réponse d'un homme alors qu'il est
occupé avec autre chose vous avez à
gérer oui et les nuits
sont compliquées oui disons elles
peuvent être plus agité que les journées
pourquoi parce qu'il a sommeil
voilà il parle beaucoup il peut danser
en normal
par contre il se lève pas là bas ils
dansent dans le lit oui oui oui derrière
cet amour imaginaire une intelligence
artificielle
ultrasophistiqués nos matches à nice
c'est amant numérique est conçu pour
apporter un soutien émotionnel là où
parfois les relations humaines ont leurs
limites c'est le truc le plus drôle
qu'il vous ait fait hausser des phrases
a surtout avec frais un cd phrase j'ai
si je te suis je suis colle à bois et
poutine
celle là elle est allée ouais il
marchera pas cadencés 6000 indigènes
venus à brasilia de toute l'amazonie
pour réclamer d'être protégés
ils veulent stopper un projet de loi du
gouvernement qui les chassent de leurs
terres de plus en plus de gens essaient
de piller nos terres ils s'introduisent
chez nous pour déboiser la forêt trouver
de l'or exploiter du minerai construire
des lignes de chemin de fer tous ses
projets meurtriers du gouvernement
dehors ball sonar ou c'est donc le
message des indigènes au président
brésilien car c'est lui qui autorise les
gisements en pleine forêt
les entreprises peuvent creuser car
seule une partie des terres sur
lesquelles les indigènes habitent leur
appartient
[Musique]
est-ce que tout
jeudi
prend la direction de l'arménie pour des
images assez étonnante un des débats
parlementaires qui ont été assez
passionné qui ont carrément tourné à la
bagarre voilà vous voyez c'est ça
surprend quand on voit ça à leur bagarre
entre des députés du pouvoir et de
l'opposition
alors ces tensions elles ont lieu à
cause du conflit avec l'azerbaïdjan et
en et lui a même été hospitalisé après
après ces bagarres internet s'est trouvé
une nouvelle occupation dangereuse
le mil creil challenge le défi des
caisses de lait en france est des
pyramides instable à gravir et à
redescendre rares sont ceux qui
parviennent le plus souvent c'est la
chute et ça peut faire très mal le
phénomène est si populaire aux états
unis que plusieurs médecins mettent en
garde contre cette pratique surtout en
cette période où les hôpitaux sont déjà
sous tension du père et du fils et du
saint esprit amen
[Musique]
si
vous le coupez comme ça
oui ça bouge et c'est quand même très
très spécial
[Musique]
ça gigote s'agit d'être
elle vous servir direct comme ça dans la
suite en train de gigoter
aller non
c'est une blague
c'est à dire que tu t'es dit tiens je
vais faire comme toi bien mais jusqu'au
bout c'est-à-dire le thé totalement
rentré dans ses pompes quoi en fait
c'est cette une j'ai bien d'autres chez
bonjour c'était champions certains à
droite 1 ouais
qu'est-ce qui se passe bat a tapé le mur
tu as bien fait il faut braquer beaucoup
plus tard
bon allez on va voir à ben voilà ah bah
voilà ça c'est fait je je vais vous dire
au revoir j'espère sept mois dernier
son père aussi j'ai bien senti concerné
on se reverra aux prud'hommes québec